it's almost like I feel like I've had a
lot of different lives and been
different women
through different stages
but maybe that's why I'm always kind of
uh unpredictable Raquel Welch has died
since my icon was 82 years old
a rep for the actress tells E.T Raquel
died peacefully on Wednesday following a
brief illness
can I trust you across a career that
spanned decades she was one of
Hollywood's most sought after Stars my
Batman is it damaged I don't know doctor
we'll have to test it her breakout roles
came in the 1960s the Fantastic Voyage
[Music]
[Applause]
and one Million Years BC the prehistoric
fantasy and its memorable poster turned
Raquel into a sex symbol around the
world a status she embraced sheer beauty
alone perhaps isn't enough
but of lots of times it gives a great
deal of joy to many people and I don't
see why it should be
perceived as some kind of disadvantage I
think it's it's great disadvantage or
not Raquel's prolific career speaks for
itself leaving behind celebrated
performances on the stage and scream
hello hello have we met you you know
most all of the movies I've I've enjoyed
making to tell you the truth they're all
have a sort of different
thing about them and I never think it's
that easy Raquel is survived by her two
children Damon and Tony Welch
[Music]
foreign foreign